lo que quiero platicar en este vídeo es
acerca de las figuras de cuatro lados y
la palabra matemática digamos que
utilizamos para nombrar a las figuras de
cuatro lados es cuadrilátero y que
justamente tenemos aquí muy bien es
cuadrilátero y siempre que veas digamos
el prefijo cuatro verdades es una muy
buena señal de que estás tratando con
algo que tiene que ver con el número
cuatro así que el cuadrilátero es una
figura que tiene cuatro lados y por
ejemplo podemos dar varios varios
dibujos de esto por ejemplo tenemos el
famoso cuadrado verdad también podríamos
tener este otro cuadrilátero quizás
debería dibujarlos bien con líneas
verdad aquí tenemos uno
este es un cuadrilátero este también es
un cuadrilátero verdad es
cuadrilátero también podríamos tener un
cuadrilátero de este estilo verdad algo
así como como
una pirámide ok que le quitamos la punta
y también podríamos tener este otro tipo
de cuadrilátero verdad un poquito
digamos nos había costado o incluso
podríamos tener algo todavía más extraño
como esto verdad pero bueno ya estos son
ejemplos de cuadriláteros que no es un
cuadrilátero por ejemplo un triángulo no
es un cuadrilátero verdad esto sólo
tiene tres lados o por ejemplo un
pentágono este este no era un pentágono
pues tampoco será un cuadrilátero éste
tiene cinco lados y por supuesto un
círculo tampoco va a ser un cuadrilátero
ninguno de éstos es cuadrilátero porque
no tienen cuatro lados verdad podríamos
pensar que el círculo pues no tiene el
podríamos pensar que no tiene lados
verdad es sólo una una sola curva ahora
que ya hemos visto ejemplos de
cuadriláteros podríamos pensar también
en las categorías de estos cuadriláteros
y quizás el primero que deberíamos
observar
paralelogramo muy bien el paralelogramo
y qué es lo que distingue a un
paralelogramo bueno esencialmente lo que
distingue a un paralelogramo es que
tiene lados opuestos que son paralelos y
tú te preguntarás bueno y qué significa
que sean paralelos quiere decir que
digamos podríamos decir que van en la
misma dirección sus lados vamos vamos a
ver un ejemplo digamos que tenemos este
este es un ejemplo de un paralelogramo
verdad este es un ejemplo de un
paralelogramo entonces tenemos que ver
que los lados opuestos van en la misma
dirección verdad por ejemplo podríamos
considerar este lado déjenme hacerlo con
un mejor color
por ejemplo entonces si tomamos este
lado ok y nos fijamos en el lado opuesto
que lo estamos digamos pintando con azul
podemos ver que van en la misma
dirección verdad no sé si le ponemos una
flecha podemos ver que va en la misma
dirección si nos fijamos en el otro lado
que voy a pintar con amarillo y nos
fijamos en su lado opuesto podemos ver
nuevamente que van en la misma dirección
verdad entonces esto es un paralelogramo
muy bien que otro paralelogramo
conocemos bueno él el famoso cuadrado es
un paralelogramo verdad este es el
cuadrado y un cuadrado es un
paralelogramo si nos fijamos por ejemplo
en estos dos lados nuevamente podemos
ver que son paralelos van en exactamente
la misma dirección y también los lados
que van digamos vertical que son
verticales verdad estos
corrijo eso estos dos lados van en la
misma dirección y por ejemplo que no
sería un paralelogramo pues algo que no
sería un paralelogramo es algo de este
estilo por ejemplo algo de este estilo
no es un paralelogramo y tú dirás oye
pero yo si veo dos lados que son
paralelos verdad por ejemplo estos dos
lados
los lados son paralelos verdad apuntan
en la misma dirección sin embargo
tenemos otros dos lados que no son
paralelos este lado y este lado no son
paralelos no van en la misma dirección y
una buena forma de ver cuando son
paralelos es por ejemplo si extendemos a
estas rectas y vemos que se cruzan
entonces no son paralelos verdad en el
caso por ejemplo que tenemos acá arriba
si los extendemos si los xxi extendemos
estas líneas pues en realidad nunca se
cruzan verdad entonces es una buena
forma de determinar cuando son paralelos
algunos lados que no sería por un
paralelogramo por ejemplo este
cuadrilátero que habíamos pintado aquí
no es un paralelogramo verdad sus lados
no son paralelos en definitiva
pensemos ahora en otra categoría
pensemos ahora en el rombo muy bien o
los rombos ok entonces un rombo es en
particular un tipo de paralelogramo
verdad es decir que sus lados son
paralelos sus lados opuestos son
paralelos pero la característica más
importante del rombo es que va a tener
los lados iguales verdad en cuanto a
longitud entonces por ejemplo si
nosotros pintamos algo así
digamos que tenemos este cuadrilátero
este por supuesto es un paralelogramo
verdad ya lo hemos visto en digamos hace
unos minutos este lado es paralelo a
este otro lado y ahora este lado es
paralelo a este otro lado sin embargo
notamos que el lado azul es mucho más
grande que el lado amarillo entonces tú
te preguntarás bueno y que si es un
rombo pues un rombo sería algo más o
menos de este estilo
o menos así
o menos así en donde ahora podemos ver
que este lado es igual a este lado que
es igual a este lado y que es igual a
este lado entonces este es un tipo de
rombo y tú a lo mejor ya estarás
incluyendo que hay otro tipo de rombo
muy famoso y si es el cuadrado verdad
tenemos el cuadrado nuevamente pues es
un paralelogramo ya vimos que es un
paralelogramo y además todos sus lados
son iguales verdad entonces de una forma
que en la que concibo los los rombos es
justamente como si este cuadrado fuera a
mucha velocidad entonces como que se
desplaza un poquito hacia atrás verdad
como si fuera una caricatura pero bueno
esa es una forma que a mí me sirve para
para distinguir a los rombos ahora vamos
con el último ejemplo y qué son los
rectángulos muy bien entonces este
nuevamente es un tipo de paralelogramo
verdad y voy a pintar un rectángulo
un rectángulo más o menos
más o menos ahí tenemos un rectángulo
verdad pero tú te estarás preguntando
bueno y qué es lo que caracteriza a los
rectángulos y quizás ya estás incluyendo
en donde se sitúa está esta
característica tan particular verdad y
esencialmente es en la forma en la que
se juntan en las esquinas verdad por
ejemplo quizás deberíamos llamarlo que
tiene una esquina en en cuadro que
digamos algo así una esquina en cuadro
es decir lo que forman es lo que
conocemos como un ángulo recto podríamos
pensar eso que podemos en embonar muy
bien un cuadrado en la esquina verdad
entonces es una forma de pensar a los
ángulos rectos podríamos ver de hecho
podríamos verlo muy rápidamente que esto
este este para este rectángulo perdón es
un paralelogramo verdad este lado es
paralelo a este otro
que es paralelo a este otro y también
tenemos este otro lado que es paralelo
al opuesto verdad entonces podemos verlo
porque si extendemos las líneas nunca se
cruzan tampoco pasa digamos hacia acá
abajo que no sería un rectángulo por
ejemplo si nosotros nos fijamos en este
que tenemos aquí verdad aquí nosotros no
podemos embonar un cuadrado verdad si
nosotros quisiéramos embonar un cuadrado
oops se sale o por ejemplo
no podríamos verdad entonces no sé
podríamos hacer algo así no encajan bien
los cuadrados en las esquinas verdad
entonces éste no es un paralelogramo
porque en la esquina no forma ángulos
rectos pero nuevamente puede ser que
tengas mucha intuición y ya estés viendo
que el cuadrado justamente es un tipo de
rectángulo verdad justamente más o menos
en términos de un cuadrado definimos que
era un rectángulo verdad que podíamos
encajar digamos o invocar un cuadrado en
las esquinas entonces el cuadrado
resulta ser muy interesante el cuadrado
es un tipo de cuadrilátero muy pero muy
interesante porque resulta ser un
cuadrilátero por supuesto también es un
paralelogramo también es un rombo y
también es un rectángulo verdad por
supuesto es un rectángulo por lo que ya
dijimos podemos ponerle cuadraditos en
las esquinas es un rombo porque todos
sus lados miden lo mismo
y es un paralelogramo porque sus lados
opuestos son paralelos